I'll expect specifics by the end of
the day regret there's an increase
in construction shipments going to scare officer
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be my
full Star Wars andor episode 4 video there were a
whole bunch of Easter eggs and references so we'll
break it all down they even had a super deep cut
for Knights of the Old Republic during the episode
that a lot of you probably picked up on but I'll
talk about that during the video if you're brand
new to the channel I'm doing videos for all the
episodes be sure to subscribe to get them careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen the episode yet
we'll just start at the beginning and work our
way through shot by shot talking about Easter
eggs and WTF moments as we go along starting with
the episode title it was called aldani which is a
reference to the planet where the Empire has
been keeping the quarterly pay for the entire
sector which is a giant giant pile of money
that they plan on robbing during the series but
this episode was mostly them planning the actual
Heist and setting up what's going to be happening
in next week's episode where they actually
probably do pull off the heist gotta pay for
that Rebellion somehow that was also a big plot
with mon mothma who they reintroduced during this
episode she's a big part of the series she's one
of the founding members of the Rebellion so this
episode is meant to explain how she sort of fits
in to the creation of the Rebellion like what she
actually did to help do that and just like they
plan on robbing this Imperial Garrison to get
all this money to pay for the Rebellion or help
pay for the Rebellion one of her major roles is
to use her position to divert a bunch of funds
that they can use for whatever it is that they
need for their missions as they try to create the
Rebellion episode 4 also kind of served as sort of
like a reintroduction to what's happening with the
actual Empire like we didn't really see the Empire
during the first couple of episodes even though
they're ever present in the Galaxy like you feel
their influence they reference them many times
in the first couple of episodes but this is the
episode where we go back to coruscot we see the
headquarters of the Imperial Security Bureau which
is sort of like the information gathering armor
of the Empire really cool connection to the events
of the Mandalorian series too even though the
Mandalorian happens way later in the timeline moff
Gideon actually came from the Imperial Security
Bureau so he'd actually be working with them like
he'd be walking around with a white uniform during
this period in the timeline his territory was
around the Mandalore Planet so that's why he was
at Mandalore during the Great Purge it's sounds
like he didn't become a moth till like much later
in the timeline during the events of the original
trilogy I don't know if we're gonna get any
Giancarlo Esposito Cameo scenes during this but it
would be cool to see like a younger version of MAF
Gideon walking around mon mothma is going to be a
really big character during the series Bale Organa
probably gonna Cameo scene because she talks about
bringing in another high-ranking member to their
circle like oh I got this new person I think could
help us out that might wind up being him because
he's also like a really major figure that's
credited with the formation of the Rebellion one
of the big surprises is that this episode was like
50 minutes long which is way longer than a lot
of the Mandalorian episodes the actual opening
scene starts with Andor and luthen jumping to
hyperspace in his ship after they escape at the
end of episode three like it starts right after
the end of episode three in this episode serves
to sort of give you more of his backstory and
explain what's going on in his daily life as he
tries to go about both forming the rebellion and
operating on Coruscant like he's a very wealthy
member operating within the Empire but that's kind
of like a character that he plays the real version
of Luthen is the version that we saw during
episode 3 that's why it seemed like he was putting
on a costume and trying to get back into character
when he went back to Coruscant like he was putting
on a character so to speak that was the mask that
he wore to disguise what he was really doing his
particular ship is a fondor hall craft fondor was
a system inside the Techno Union during the Clone
Wars there are a lot of Clone Wars references
during the episode like most of the places the
people that they reference are from the Clone
Wars but there are also some references to stuff
that happened during Star Wars Rebels as well
that's another series that details the resistance
becoming the Rebellion because they were called
the resistance before they actually became the
Rebellion that didn't happen until a little bit
later in the timeline so like right now during the
events of these episodes they're still called the
resistance I believe the med knock that he gives
him is like a brand new thing to Star Wars but
I love the idea that they have medical booze for
healing yourself when you don't have an actual
full back to tank they also use the first part
of this episode to show you andor's relationship
with the Rebellion like at first he doesn't want
to have anything to do with it and he's doing
it because he's paid to I think the idea is
that eventually he'll come around and believe in
their cause the funny thing with him catching him
in the LIE early on is the idea that Andor has
gotten so used to lying that he just lies about
everything but obviously that works in his favor
because this whole thing is spycraft he's trying
to stay under the radar so he'd have to be a very
good liar when he mentions the Battle of minbin
that he fought in for the Empire when he was 16
years old that was after the Clone Wars like this
wasn't the Clone Wars this was happening during
the events of Star Wars solo you actually see Han
Solo's backstory he fought in that same battle and
we find out that both of them actually deserted
the Empire during the battle Andor apparently
came there as a cook and he deserted that's
how he survived like that's the big story in this
episode but also Han Solo rescued Chewbacca during
that battle and they both deserted they said at
the heist that they're going to pull off early
in the series here it sounds like it's going to
happen in episode 5 but the idea is they're gonna
steal the payroll for the entire sector worth
of Imperial officers which is just like a giant
amount of money obviously the Rebellion costs a
ton of money like you have to get all those ships
all those weapons from somewhere a lot of it they
wound up still feeling a lot of people gave them
ships a lot of them they stole from the Empire and
a lot of them they actually did have to pay for
one of the reasons why the new Republic later on
allows the Hutts to continue operating doing all
their black market trade is because the Hutts were
kind of neutral and they also sold weapons to the
rebels in addition to the Empire so technically
the rebels kind of owed them a solid so they're
like okay fine you're kind of shady but we'll
let you continue doing what you're doing because
without you we wouldn't have been able to pull off
the Rebellion but that's part of mon mothma's role
too like high level she can get them tons of money
that they use to pay for all this stuff this is a
really cool Easter egg when Luthen gives him the
blue kyber crystal obviously kyber crystals are
using the creation of Jedi's lightsabers this is
a blue one so it's a blue lightsaber it's the same
color as Anakin's lightsabers the Empire also used
a massive number of kyber crystals in the creation
of their super laser for the Death Star they also
reference the Death Star during this episode too
but in like a roundabout way like it's kind of
a secret within the Empire itself the whole idea
that even within the Imperial power structure
they come departmentalized a lot of information
but like this is another callback to the events of
Rogue one because this is meant to be a rogue one
prequel and we see them creating the Death Star
within the Imperial Security Bureau like they
reference a bunch of resources being diverted
to scarif that's the location where krennic
was supervising the creation of the Death Star
krennic was also part of the Imperial Security
Bureau that's why he wore a white uniform but
the other big reference to the kyber crystal that
they make is two the Knights of the Old Republic
video games a lot of you probably realized this
when he mentions the rakatan Invaders so the
whole idea is that within the Knights of the
Old Republic games the rakatan empire was sort of
like this ancient empire that existed more than 25
000 years ago that use these special Infinity
gates to control the entire galaxy almost the
entire universe during their Heyday the ancient
Jedi Empire at that time tried to fight them off
along with Rebels so the crystal is meant to
be a reference to the Rebellion against that
Empire in a reference to the current Rebellion
that's forming against this current Empire they
also explain how he came into possession of the
crystal so his day job Within in the Empire is
like a merchant selling historical items he
owns his gallery and that's how he knows all
this ancient history then we finally go back to
Coruscant we see the headquarters of the Imperial
Security Bureau in this Council of lieutenants and
Majors like its high ranking but like the leader
here is a major so you don't see a whole bunch
of Admirals all sitting around this new main
character is Dedra she's sort of like a version of
Karn within the Empire like someone who's obsessed
with finding out what's actually going on with
the Rebellion the whole idea with her is that
she thinks she sees the Rebellion forming which
he's obviously correct about but none of her other
co-workers believe her is a bit of a parallel
for what happened with Karn even though what's
happening with him was on a smaller scale like
he had include into the larger Rebellion that's
forming so she's kind of like an upgraded version
of him everyone probably recognized Anton lesser
who's playing major part of gas he's leading the
council here he played maester qyburn from Game
of Thrones he's been on a bunch of other stuff too
but most people remember him from Game of Thrones
they also had another Game of Thrones actor during
the series I'll talk about later too but this
just meant to show you what their inner workings
were like within the Imperial Security Bureau
they're kind of like the FBI within the Empire
like this domestic security Force controlling the
entire galaxy just monitoring everything they're
mostly viewed as an information gathering arm
there's another huge Mandalorian Easter egg too
he mentions arvala six arvala 7 is the planet
that Mando found grogu on during the Mandalorian
season one so the idea is that grogu was hiding
underneath the Empire's nose this whole time and
they never realized it the way they portray his
character he's like a more competent version of
krennic like more aware of what's going on he's
a little bit more like Tarkin in that fact when he
talks about the nature of their work talking about
how they're like Health Care Providers trying to
cure disease from within and outside of the Empire
that's a reference to like all these high-ranking
people like mon mothma the other people that are
on aldani because you have a lot of officers
within the Empire working to actively destroy
it the other new lieutenant character blevin
brings things back around to the events of the
first few episodes in the morlana sector and they
were revealed the Empire's recovered starpath unit
but obviously that becomes a larger plot in the
episode too Dedra references that the star path
unit was stolen from a unit within her sector she
also makes it sound like it had been lost again
like it had been stolen again after the Empire
had rescued it after that big fire fight I think
that has more to do with the big storyline
like she'll be going after Bix looking for
the star path unit because Bix is a much bigger
character and her old thing was that she wanted
the star path unit initially before they lost
it they also set up this internal conflict with
Dedra vs blevin within the ISB and that's just to
show you how there's no love between members in
the Empire and that's one of the things that the
rebels used against them like maybe if they all
did a better job of working together the rebels
wouldn't have had a chance but very clearly she's
figured out what luthin is doing all over the
Galaxy but just nobody believes her right now
that'll probably change after the heist happens
after they steal all that money like okay you
know what there might actually be something going
on here they introduced the valsartha character
played by Faye Marseille who is the other Game
of Thrones actor in the episode there might be
some other other background actors too but she's
the other big one she played the wave within the
context of this series she's basically like
a bigger team leader for the resistance their
group mentions saw Guerrera who we actually saw in
the trailer so we'll see him in later episodes he
was another figure that the rebels were kind of
wary of because he was so stabby but that helped
the rebels so they kind of owed him a debt he was
sort of like the rebels version of The Punisher
like within the Marvel Universe The Punisher is
kind of like an anti-hero character because he's
so stabby saw Guerrera does the same thing for
the rebels during the events of the series and
they use the rest of this part of the storyline to
just set up the actual Heist they also set up the
idea that I'm using that special Celestial
event around the base that's going to help
them Escape they also explained what happens to
Karen's character in that storyline when blevin
comes into morlana and basically says the Empire
is going to take over the entire area like the
corporation will no longer control this part of
space which is exactly what his supervisor told
him they wanted to avoid like we do not want to
alert the Empire it will only be bad for all of
us it seems like he goes back to Coruscant to his
mother's house with his tail between his legs so
it sounds like he'll have some intersection with
the Dedra character because they're both kind of
like the same type of character clueing into
what's actually going on when he comes back at
the starport here they mentioned hostian prime in
platform 7 that's actually one of the planets that
the first order destroyed with the Starkiller base
the Super Death Star it had become the capital of
the new Republic during Star Wars Episode VII then
when we go back to Luthen's shop we meet his aide
Clea who's another member of this Inner Circle
helping the Rebellion I think one of the ideas
too is a lot of these historical items that you
see around the shop and some of them are Easter
eggs were actually stolen by the Empire after the
events of the prequels if this armor suit looks
familiar it's because it is Jango fed's armor
from Attack of the Clones apparently earlier in
the timeline before Boba Fett got it it came into
luthen's possession Boba Fett at some point after
this would have gotten it from him and turned
it into his armor I'm sure there'll be a bunch
of timeline questions after this too like wait a
minute when did Boba Fett get the armor back from
him he and man mothma do some secret planning but
she arrives under the pretense of buying her her
husband Perrin who were meeting for the first time
I don't think we've actually learned about her
husband before in Star Wars to buy him a birthday
present which they say is for his day of days like
the chandralin version of Life Day. Life Day
within the Star Wars universe is something from
the Star Wars holiday special but it's basically
like The Wookie version of birthdays they've
referenced it many times during the Mandalorian
series when he mentions the weapon from uttapow
that's the planet from Revenge of the Sith where
Obi-Wan Kenobi fought General Grievous hello there
General Kenobi some of the items around here
are Easter eggs I believe that the armor suit
in the background here is meant to be an ancient
Mandalorian suit then we go back to mon mothman's
home on Coruscant it sounds like her husband isn't
in on all the Rebellion plant like he doesn't know
what she's actually doing because he talks about
this big party that she's throwing with a bunch
of high-ranking members inside the Imperial
Senate in the emperor's Inner Circle most of
the characters that she mentions on the guest list
are prequels characters that we saw like sly moore
the vizier that she mentions is the grand vizier
mas amedda they're all super high-ranking members
of The Emperor's Inner Circle like basically like
the worst group of people that you could possibly
imagine that she has to have dinner with that's
probably what all this footage in the trailer is
from from the party that she throws where they
come she also kind of explains her relationship
with them within the Empire like they all kind
of hate her because she actually tries to use
her power for good which is one of the reasons
why the emperor before the events of A New Hope
dissolves the Senate completely like okay let's
just get rid of that problem we don't want people
helping everyone else when she references
Ghorman she's talking about the atrocities
that the Empire committed on the planet it
was featured during Star Wars Rebels the way
they present her husband in the episode is that
he isn't like a bad character or anything like
that he's not evil it's just that he doesn't know
exactly what's going on and he's one of the many
high-ranking members within the Empire who just
kind of blind to what they're actually doing like
we got all these really powerful people coming
they're all super fun to talk to and you have
mon mothma trying to remind him no no these are
all terrible people they commit atrocities every
day then at the end of the episode when Dedre is
talking to Anton Lesnar's character he mentions
Sev Tok that's another planet from the Clone Wars
but also they basically set up the idea that she's
probably gonna do the same thing that Karn did
in the first couple of episodes like she's told
to just leave it alone pretty safe bet she's not
gonna do that and she'll do exactly what Karn did
and just go rogue on it but remember his whole
thing is that he said wait till you have more
concrete evidence the evidence will probably
come when they pull off the heist like look at
this giant pile of money that they stole from us
clearly something is going on and it sounds like
that actual Heist will happen during episode 5
but if you spotted any other Easter egg in the
episode that I didn't talk about in the video
just write down below in the comments there's
probably a lot more Easter eggs in the background
of some of these scenes too my full Andor episode
6 video will post next week after they release
it and I'll put a link down in the description
for all my other Andor episodes click here for my
new Deadpool 3 Wolverine trailer video revealing
Hugh Jackman coming back as Wolverine and click
here for my house of the Dragon episode 7 video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!